peggy 18. a snake flicks its tongue as a
leather boot steps past it up stone
steps a bearded dark-haired man removes
a hood he is in a columned cavern
a secret ceremony
are you ready to give up who you once
thought you were i am a ubisoft original
a hand runs along an ornate carpet
beardless the dark head man moves
through a bustling bazaar
vendors bargain tea is poured
ready to sacrifice everything your
health clothes
i am a dark-haired woman stares
a merchant bumps a vendor the darkhead
man snatches a coin purse from the
vendor's waist but guards pursue him
at the ceremony
are you ready to leave your life behind
and walk the path of shadows
i am the dark-haired man takes a heated
blade in ancient baghdad he flees the
guards through a darkened tunnel he
pulls a market stall down behind him
tripping a guard
a guard swings a sword at the
dark-haired man as he tries to climb a
city wall but falls to the ground the
guard backhands him as others surround
him two of the three guards dropped to
the ground with knives protruding from
their backs a hooded dark-haired
assassin swings down from the
scaffolding taking out the remaining
guard
then out of the dark you will come into
the light in a darkened tower he appears
bearded and wearing an assassin's hood
as she helps him up he blocks her blade
as she swings at him they block and duck
one another's blows out onto scaffolding
surrounding the unfinished tower he
pursues her to an edge he smirks then
lunges she twists behind him then pushes
him over the edge
and from the light in the ceremony
you will return to the dark she covers
embers
he lowers the heated blade over his left
hand she gazes towards him
he grimaces
he clutches his hand
never forget the tenets you have sworn
to uphold standing on a tower he
overlooks sprawling baghdad soldiers
escort a nobleman past beggars
stay your blade from the flesh of the
innocent missing a ring finger the
dark-haired man reaches out hide in
plain sight he impales three soldiers
with a hidden blade
never compromise the brotherhood the
nobleman points as his soldiers charge
at the darkhead man who throws a smoke
bomb the air fills with red smoke then
fades to reveal the darkhead man as he
kills two more men soldiers chase after
him he glances at a hawk flying overhead
then climbs onto a rooftop a soldier
collapses from poisonous gas two
remaining soldiers rush the nobleman
down an alley to a courtyard
a soldier hurls flaming material from a
fire at the assassin who dodges it the
assassin uses the second soldier as a
human shield before stabbing the first
from this day forward the nobleman tries
to flee you are
a hidden one the darkhead man drops down
in front of the nobleman who swings a
knife wildly the nobleman checks his
waist as the assassin throws a golden
mask to the ground he hurls sand back at
the assassin who dunks it the assassin
twists behind him then puts a blade to
his neck
title assassin's creed mirage
in a realm of shadows the assassin looks
up from the nobleman
wreathed in grey smoke a ghoulish
creature stares back at him
assassin's creed mirage coming 2023
[Music]
you